[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laisse le Jumbo où qu'il aille viens
faire un beau voyage de paille plus de
bar vieux Chand on
taille bye
bye c'est une Micheline ha
d'ora quire qui fume qui travaille de la
Poti sur des rails dentelle et
Sky toute la nuit les jolis B nous
feront bouger ça fera du boogie woogie
g avec le champagne suis pas sûr dans le
tunnel noir on F pas l'amour dans le
couloir laisse les Séchelles
aublasé prospectus au
panier c'est du décor du papier du pré
fabriqué c'est une diaiselle
confançé de roues motrices cylindr en vé
les gardes fressé chaud le café vite
baisé
sucré la vitesse est telle qui la vit
est le tunnel et nous la tout nu à Vitel
tu as un CIN de beauté que j'avais pas
vu tout à l'heure sur ta peau là où il y
a le
[Musique]
cœur Micheline lézard quel
panard via du rivière
bazar et vive l'erreur
d'aiguillage qui nous laisserait toi et
moi de mois sur voie de mois sur voie de
mois sur voie
garage contre les compagnies aériennes
je n'ai aucun GF mais tout de même
[Musique]
SNCF